[Music]
in this video you will learn how to
enable and connect to the serial console
for google compute engine or gc virtual
machine instances running on linux
operating system
to begin with let's understand what a
serial console is
serial console allows users to access
virtual machine instances through a
virtual serial connection
typically in linux systems the first
serial port is used as the serial
console
you may be wondering why do i need a
serial console
when an instance is inaccessible over a
network for example when ssh fails or
the vm is partially booted you can
access the instance by using its serial
console
thereby enables you to troubleshoot
boot networking issues and also interact
with the bootloader
by default the serial console is
disabled to restrict access and google
recommends that you use it only for
troubleshooting purposes
to use serial console you must enable it
either at the project level for all
instances or at an instance level for a
specific instance
remember if there is an instance level
setting present then it overrides any
project level setting
before enabling the access to the serial
console remember that access to the
serial console can be disabled by
setting an organization policy which
disables interactive serial console
access to all vms for all the projects
that are part of the organization
you can turn off the enforcement of the
organization level policy on a per
project basis by following the steps in
this documentation
now let's jump into the google cloud
console and learn how to enable access
to the serial console at an instance
level
go to compute engine vm instances page
click on the instance you want to enable
access for
in our example we will select my
instance which is currently inaccessible
over the network
click edit
in the remote access section
check enable connecting to the serial
ports box and save your changes
now we can connect to the serial console
using google cloud console the google
cloud cli or third-party ssh client
provided that ssh client lets you to
connect to the tcp port
9600
in our demo we will access the
problematic instance
my instance through the serial console
by using google cloud console
select my instance
in the remote access section
click connect to the serial console to
connect to default port
port 1.
as we see in the serial console
the instance is in emergency mode
and is not booting up thereby making it
inaccessible through ssh congratulations
we have successfully used the serial
console to determine the cause of vm
inaccessibility
now let's look at another scenario when
a vm is booted but isn't accessible over
the network you must enter your login
credential through the serial console
by default google supplied linux system
images are not configured to allow
password-based logins for local users
one of the ways to overcome this
limitation is to set up a local password
by using a startup script
to configure a startup script that sets
a local user assigns that user a
password and gives them a permission to
operate as root
we will do the following
in the cloud console go to vm instances
page
select the vm for which you want to add
the local password
click edit
in
startup script section enter the
following script
you can find the script in our
documentation shared in the description
below click save
reset the vm to initialize startup
script
then connect to serial console
enter your login information
congratulations we have now successfully
logged into the vm instance through the
serial console even though the instance
was not accessible through ssh
thereby enabling us to troubleshoot
further at the operating system level
check out this documentation for further
tips and tricks you can use while
connecting to the gc instances through
the serial console
[Music]
you